being unique is far more powerful than
being the best if possible be first now
that probably applies to zero of us
because you might be like Sean there is
zero opportunity to be first right now
on YouTube depends though AI is blowing
up right now there's already a lot of
people that have rushed in to capture
the positioning of being first to
educating people about AI if you can
have a first mover's advantage that's an
option but here's the key if you can't
be first then your goal is to position
yourself against the person who got
there first for example 7ep positioned
itself against Coca-Cola as the uncola
and crushed it